avec la langue et je sais qu'à certains
chroniqueurs qui ont écrit une lettre à
quelqu'un qui leur étaient chers eux qui
veut qu yves qui vont lire une qui voit
la paille et vous l'avez écrit vous avez
créé fatou j'ai écrit une lettre à fatto
et à la fin tout allait pas là c'est pas
sophie dans j'aime ton prénom
donc c'est sa fiancée option si sa fille
gemma son aigle larguèrent mois qui
vient de larguer je craque tout à fait
encore ses actions ce qui l'a largué ses
plongées rennaises pour la récupérer on
va voir je vous regarde vous comme si
vous étiez fatah au caire fatou j'aime
ton prêt donc j'aime tes mots j'aime ton
âme
j'aime ton corps j'aime tes regards et
même des absences
je les aime car elle renforce mon amour
mais c'est ton coeur qui m'embrasse
j'aime la vie avec toi car sans toi ce
n'est pas la vie c'est un désert où même
le sable se fossilise alors il ya to
kill et moi j'aime quand tu fermes ta
gueule
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle pourquoi marie oui ça va le
surprend parce que je suis pas
romantique à pour le marc hé regardez à
la crise est à son mari alors à toi mon
homme j'aime parce que nous avons réussi
à être presque vieux sans être
complètement adultes parce que nous
avons si peu vu passer le temps que nous
avons encore nos meubles d'étudiants
parce que nous faisons toujours l'amour
et l'humour et surtout parce que nous
rions toujours ensemble entre deux ans
de la d3 drame alors oui alain comme dit
l'autre je t'aime plus qu'hier et moins
que demain alors il fait beau
on a attrapé d'alain qui dit qui est
cette personne
on n'a qu'à aller on va demander à aller
à raymond gurême en un mois j'ai moi
c'est les persans alors des personnes
qu'on aime les personnes qui j'en avais
plein j'en avais plein de s'y marier
plein de choses ces dernières années je
n'avais pas mes coups mais comme je vais
quand même aller quand même prendre mes
enfants en fait parce que j'ai deux
enfants formidables tristan je suis fier
de toi tu fais tout ce que je ne fais
pas tu travaille bien à l'école tu fais
des études de chimie tu m'a scotché donc
tu m'aides à tous les jours hatton à
tenir debout et à me battre pour vous
audrey tu fais aussi des études
formidables et je t'aime ma fille malgré
ton parcours
je t'aime beaucoup et je veux que tu
continues aussi tes études
en ce moment je vous vois pas beaucoup
parce que je pars très tôt je rentrais
tard mais on va on va prendre du temps
ensemble et voilà je voulais dire à mes
enfants que j'étais même très très fort
ah les gens me ou mathieu et après
j'aurais une lettre pour ce que j'ai
écrit un poème mai ah oui il va être à
l'aise y apprend phrases ont mis à les y
met mais moi je pleure vite mais j'ai
pour mon ami jean me ayé but parce que
c'est vraiment et puis j'ai eu besoin
alors c'est ridicule cher j'ai remis une
poésie à mon niveau littéraire c'est
dire si ces faibles sans me juger dès le
début dans tpm paix tu m'as accepter ta
culture tu as eu un peu me l'inculquer
chaque semaine c'est toi c'est avec des
sushis qu'on a dîné c'est vrai quand
j'ai pété un plomb seul toit savait me
calmer quand j'étais triste lerner dans
ta chambre d'amis un lit tu dépliait de
mes amis aujourd'hui et puis le pilier
alors merci d'être mon meilleur ami et
pas que dans tpm p
mais bon je sens que vous adorez cette
séquence lan fait plaisir cette séquence
est tellement merveilleux qui dévalorise
dans l'émission ils font toujours croire
qu'il est radin qui n'est pas sensible
accès annette qui est tout en
sensibilité que je les adore évidemment
bonjour mitaine les toits ou une petite
lettre parce que mes bras mais pour
mathieu
non non mais il sait tous que le bien
que je pense de lui on va se voir plus
tiens ça tu me vois tellement que tu ne
me regardent plus pourtant moi je n'ai
d'yeux que pour toi si je travaillais
moi je passerai mes journées à tomates
et en replay à écouter des paroles qui
coulerait dans ma gorge qui ont du bon
miel
je serai toujours là pour toi je t'aime
cyril disant tout les jours je voit plus
que mes enfants à sa malheureuse ils
font de la pub avec la langue ses amis
ont brassé mathieu pour le remercier
c'est vrai que non mais parce que j'ai
peur du corps aux navires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]